Nhan phút tổng hòa công ty chọng tâm bình lĩ nhiện nhất hệ nhớ
Họ sinh 2 cả chính lượng ngày video này về đệ xa phát sử nạn chung lắm nè
Trong sự vật lĩ nhiệt thì đây là một chung trình mà rất là nặng lịch thuết
Việc trên lòng rất là ít công thức và rất là ít giạm mai tập
Thế nhưng, kai hôm nay, mình tổng hòa trọng hòa những công thức quan trọng nhất
Vụ chương vật lĩ nhiệt và công như là cái cách át dụng nước chung nhạc
Công đứa nổ tiên là lại công thức ở trong lực lần 1 gì nữa lúc học
Nói vệ bức biến thiên lỗi nạn nhan tạo lưng của một vật sẽ bằng tổng gân và nhìn lượng
Mà vật nhất được
Và gì nhan sẽ còn chừng hợp của tương a từng quý
Nói sẽ khăn hào về chào
Nhan tạo uống 1, 2, quý, trong trường a dương là vật nhất công
Ám là vật thức khích cầu
Quý dương là vật nhất năng lượng nhạc
Và quý em là vật truyền năng lượng nhạc các bạn nhạc
Thế thì tưởng bài phản mồ các bạn phải xem là quý dương thật quý em
A dương em đến thái số ở đây cho nó chính thạc
Đó kế cho nó nó tên
Còn nó xuân hành là chỉ là công thức tính nhạc lượng trong quá trình chuyển nhạc
Hãy khác là quá trình làm thái đồ gì đâu các bạn
Thì chúng ta sẽ có một công thức tính nhạc lượng quý bằng mà dính xe nhên nè là tìm
Với mà là khủy lượng các bạn tính thường là vì là ký lượng ám
xe là có là ký dương dương của chắc là bật
Mô chắc là bật là xe có một nè dương dương khác nhau của anh nhạc
Nên vị là dương chỉ ký lượng ám được cả
Tế là tây được có là đột tăng nhạc lượng các bạn
Thì là lượng miem lượng như đột của bạn
Thống thường là sẽ lấy là như đột lúc sau cho như đột chức
Tho anh nhạc
Thì là đây là tốt xuân hành
Công thức xo ai là công thức chuyển nhạc
Trong quá trình nóm trời
Tất là khi bắt đầu sảy ra trạc thái nóm trời
Cái bắt cần chuyển cho một như lượng
Cần thiết để cái chất giản của chúng ta nóm trời hoàn toàn
Bánh chất lòng thì chúng ta sẽ cần chuyển một như lượng
Với công thức nhìn sau, quý bằng năng là nè vào
Với quý là như lượng cần chuyển cho bạn
Mà là khối lượng của bạn
Và nằm là giữ nóm trời giường
Còn như nóm trời giường này sẽ tình chất nóm trời kháng nhau
Nó thưa nóm thường dây dùng dường
Và đây là cụt thức xo ai
Công thức cuối cùng trong trường này và các thứ như
Hẹn thức tính nhạc lượng trong quá trình quá hình
Hãy khác là chỉ là giữ lượng để là một chất nào đó
Quả hơi hoàn toàn có khối lượng là mở
Thì công thức của chúng ta là quý bằng lợi nhìn mở
Với quý là như lượng cần chuyển cho bạn
Mà là khối lượng của bạn
Và là cao đây người ta phải là như hỏa hơi dùng
Lạc trường cho cường trời là vật
Bình bị là dung trị kiểu gàm
Và đây là cường công thức cần mạch
Và các bạn cần phải nhớ trong trường mở vào lĩnh nhật
Lã nhờ